dans un premier temps madame la ministre
je ne peux que rappeler que le contexte
de l'actuelle vague épidémique nous
donne raison concernant la vaccination
obligatoire et pour différentes que soit
la situation dans son pays le choix du
futur chancelier allemand en faveur
d'une obligation vaccinale sur
initiative parlementaire que vous avez
refusé ne fait que le confirmer sur un
autre registre les informations
relatives à la santé des enfants sont
aujourd'hui préoccupante qui incite la
haute autorité de santé a recommandé la
vaccination prioritaire des enfants de
moins de 12 ans un risque de formes
graves ou vivant dans l'entourage de
personnes vulnérables il y a deux jours
en effet 69 enfants de 0 à 9 ans était
hospitalisée du fait de lakovic 19 et 53
de 10 à 19 ans si depuis le début de
l'épidémie il n'y a eu que 13 décès
d'enfants de 0 à 19 ans si j'ose dire
nous en comptons neuf depuis la mi juin
et 3 ces derniers dix jours nous
considérons comme tous ici que c'est
beaucoup trop si l'erreur a été commise
de confondre moindre risque pour les
enfants avec absence de risque les
données qui nous sont présentés
aujourd'hui ne nous y autorise plus je
rappelle par ailleurs que les enfants
sont également accessibles aux séquelles
du coville long et au traumatisme lié à
la crainte d'être à l'origine de la
contamination de proches vulnérables
dans ce contexte le choix de laisser
circuler le virus au sein des écoles et
de favoriser la continuité en maintenant
les classes ouvertes delà du raisonnable
n'est plus recevable c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous demande madame la
ministre quels sont les moyens que vous
choisissez de déployer et à quelle
échéance pour la minimisation du risque
à l'école pour vous répondre
brigitte bourguignon de la parole oui
madame la sénatrice monique lubin depuis
plusieurs semaines je pense que chacun
doit avoir un peu d'humilité par rapport
à ce virus qui circule activement dans
tous les pays notamment en europe de
l'est et du nord notre pays
merci notre pays n'est plus épargnée par
cette cinquième vase et puis épidémie
violente vous le savez avec un taux
d'incidence en hausse forte désormais
supérieur à 300 le nombre d'admissions
qu'ovide à l'hôpital y compris en soins
critiques progresse la situation reste
tendue en outre-mer par ailleurs un
nouveau variant préoccupant a été
identifié vous le savez le mikron notre
pays prend donc les mesures
proportionnées à chacune des étapes de
cette crise sanitaire les vols d'afrique
australe où il fut détectée sont
suspendus jusqu'à samedi de nouvelles
mesures aux frontières ont également été
annoncés oui je sais ce midi par le
porte-parole du gouvernement plusieurs
cas sont observés en europe ton caca en
france à la réunion le dépistage pour
contenir son développement et les études
pour sa contagiosité sont en cours et
nous prendrons les mesures y compris sur
les enfants dont vous parlez dès lors
que nous aurons le résultat par les
hautes autorités sanitaires après
consultations et concertations
nous avons ouvert le rappel vaccinal
comme à chaque étape à tous les adultes
à partir de cinq mois après la
précédente injections sur la base de
nouvelles recommandations toujours de la
haute autorité de santé en pratique cela
concerne 25 millions de français dont
7,7 millions ont déjà leurs appels pour
mener cette vaste campagne il nous faut
la mobilisation de tous nous comptons
sur les libéraux les pharmaciens les
infirmer qui seront valorisés pour cela
n'aurait armand plusieurs centaines de
centres de vaccination partout en france
le rappel vaccinal sera intégré au pass
annie terre nous réactivons aussi la
ligne prioritaire pour les personnes
âgées fragiles qui ne trouvent pas de
rendez-vous immédiat bref dès le 15
décembre pour les personnes de plus de
65 ans le pass sanitaire intégrera cette
dose est ensuite à compter du 15 janvier
pour les autres publics enfin masqué
rétabli en intérieur les préfets haute
autorité pour l'imposer lors des
rassemblements expérience
madame la ministre vous n'avez
visiblement pas entendu ma question et
vous n'avez absolument pas répondu
quelle que soit la mauvaise humeur dont
vous fassiez preuve là à l'instant et
donc moi je vous parle simplement des
écoles où depuis le début on assiste
quand même à une certaine cacophonie et
croyez-moi nous gardons beaucoup de
modestie parce que nous savons quand la
période les choix sont particulièrement
difficiles mais il existe aujourd'hui
des techniques notamment des techniques
de pouline qui permettrait qui
permettrait de mieux traiter les enfants
et de mieux encadrer cette question là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]